[Musique]
l'histoire de cette contrée commence à
la fin des grandes glaciations quand les
hommes primitifs migrent en masse vers
le continent européen
attiré par son climat devenu tempéré et
par ces animaux facile à chasser
certains de ceux qui rentrent dans la
france d'aujourd'hui s'installe sur le
grand coteau calcaire aux pentes sa bru
qui borde la vienne et de la haute
domine la vallée
[Musique]
au début ils logent dans des habitats
troglodytiques puis leurs descendants
entoure le grand coteau d'une palissade
et une agglomération d'habitations
proches les unes des autres et bâti
[Musique]
sept mille ans c'est cool quand une
tribu migrantes d'origine germanique
arrive entre la loire et la vienne ce
métis avec les natifs et forme le peuple
et huronne le mot turow signifie fort
les turone ont l'europe y dom principal
à amboise érige plusieurs citadelle dont
l'ancien chinon en bas du grand coteau
de la vienne et vivent sereinement
pendant des siècles mais un mauvais jour
les légions romaines arin se vengeant
d'un ancien kia je subis rome déclenché
la guerre d'ego jules césar et ses
troupes
passez les alpes et prennent leurs
quartiers d'hiver celle et hurun bientôt
ceux-ci se rebelle et joint à d'autres
peuples gaulois
ap ap césar
mais césar est invincible
il bat la coalition gauloise et soumet
la gaule toute entière les gaulois
deviennent ainsi gallo romains et
l'empereur auguste donne un statut de
cité libre à la nouvelle capitale des
turone c'est à rodome l'ancienne tour
située à la jonction de la loire et du
cher y élit fiant l'un des plus grands
amphithéâtres de l' empire
[Musique]
la paix règne dans l' empire romain
polythéistes quand une nouvelle fois le
christianisme anime les esprits un
officier romain devenu chrétien martin
partage son manteau avec un démuni je
fais moines et épouse la condition des
plus pauvres
[Musique]
élu évêque à tour martin converti
l'aristocratie gallo-romaine et sa
figure légendaire fait des émules des
monastères et des sanctuaires sont alors
édifié
[Musique]
mais le siècle suivant le calme est
troublée
une horde de peuples germains envahi la
gauche les wisigoths occupe des
territoires jusqu'à la loire ils sont
battus près de la vienne est poussé en
espagne par clovis le jeune roi des
francs qui prend la gold toute entière
premier roi de l'ancienne france clovis
se fait baptiser et dédie son succès à
saint martin de tours
le royaume franc fait face aux divisions
et aux reconstitutions qu'en venant
d'espagne des milliers de sarrasin armés
jusqu'aux dents parce poitiers traverse
la vienne et hurlant se dirige vers tout
[Musique]
c'est le chaos
alors à nouveau cep et de la vienne que
se décide le sort de la france
le maire du palais par le martèle arrive
par les sarrasins et les repousse en
espagne le pays se libèrent des
musulmans mais non pas des bandits les
marchands sont systématiquement volée et
les riches sanctuaires sont pillées par
les armées catholique de passage
charlemagne rétabli l'ordre et au
concile de tours impose la substitution
du latin par une langue vulgaire ancêtre
du français
[Musique]
mais l'après charlemagne est désastreux
les vikings pis la france et reçoivent
le duché de normandie pour qu'il se
calme mais leurs incursions ne cesse pas
pour autant quant au trône de france
les vassaux sont à discipliner les
chevaliers forme d'une nouvelle élite
guerrière et les héritiers prétendants à
la couronne frères et cousins entre eux
se chamaillent s'éliminant l'un l'autre
par dessus les lois et la morale
[Musique]
en touraine les familles d anjou et
déploie sont plus puissantes que le roi
et s'affrontent dans une lutte haineuse
pour devenir les maîtres du territoire
le fier niveau 3 de blois refuse même
l'hommage au roi de france mais il est
exproprié de ses possessions débattue
par les anges ou qui reçoivent le comté
de touraine tout entier
c'est l'époque des premiers châteaux
médiévaux infor est érigée à loudun par
geoffroy premier d'anjou l'île bouchard
est fortifié par péloquin premier et
l'ancien bastion galles euromat de
camping accusent devenu champigny sur
veude est transformé en forteresse par
son premier seigneur le chevalier
bernier
[Musique]
non loin de là au château de chinon le
comte d'anjou henri plantagenêt assemble
terre et titre il et vassal du roi de
france et m d'un territoire très étendu
sa richesse permet la construction de
nombreux couvent et de somptueux château
mais un problème se pose quand il est
sacré roi d'angleterre sous le nom
d'henri 2
[Musique]
cet empire plantagenêt qu'il fonde
joignant ses possessions françaises à
l'angleterre alarme le très jeune roi de
france philippe auguste qui n'a aucune
intention de rapetisser son royaume
[Musique]
pour sa part henri donné roi
d'angleterre que par héritage lui et sa
famille sont tourangeau et leur mode de
vie et français ils préfèrent vivre à
chinon plutôt qu en angleterre
[Musique]
c'est à chinon qu'hummer henry 2 est que
plus tard meurt son fils richard coeur
de lion
l'empiré plantagenêt passe alors au
cruel jean sans terre
et celui ci considère que ces terres en
france ne font qu'un avec celle
d'angleterre
[Musique]
alors wa magnifique philippe auguste bat
jean sans terre l'obligent à renoncer à
ses possessions françaises par le traité
de chinon et ajoute la touraine au
domaine de la couronne de france
[Musique]
depuis le climat doux et le beau paysage
attire les souverains français dans le
château de tours dans les forteresses
royale de chinon d'amboise deloche de
langeais et dans les nombreux châteaux
de la loire érigé par la famille d'anjou
[Musique]
la touraine prend place au coeur de
l'histoire de france et débute alors la
renaissance mais le conflit contre les
anglais n'est pas terminée la chevalerie
française est mise en déroute et lors de
la bataille d'azincourt le seigneur de
l'île bouchard moeurs aux roumains de
plus les bourguignons s'allie aux
anglais et prennent paris
le roi charles vi est atteint par la
folie et le dauphin charles s'enfuit à
bourges
pour finir en absence d'un roi sacré
enrichissent d'angleterre revendiquent
le trône de france par héritage
[Musique]
la situation est gravissime des anglais
joint aux bourguignons sont
militairement plus fort alors à nouveaux
frais de la vienne se décide
l'histoire de france le jeune dauphin
charles réunit les états généraux au
château de chinon
mais il est perturbé par les événements
il est même réticent a rencontré jeanne
d'arc charles craint que sa montée au
trône puisse être associé à une probable
sorcière elle dit entendre des voix
le fait est que cette puce elle sans
laquelle la france serait aujourd'hui un
conte et du royaume uni arrive à chinon
persuade charles de lui confier une
armée prend des chevaux de combat au
château du rivau libère orléans des
anglais et renverse le cours de la
guerre
[Musique]
le château du rivau réputé pour ses
écuries domine la vallée de la vienne et
de l'aveu de permettant de surveiller
les grandes routes son seigneur pierre
de beaux vous l'a transformé en
forteresse imprenable la guerre de cent
ans se termine enfin la touraine devient
le jardin de la france est la capitale
des rois
françois premier demeure dans le château
d'amboise et léonard de vinci s'installe
près de lui
à champigny sur veude louis de bourbon
vendôme et son fils louis de montpensier
remplace l'ancien fortin par un château
et bâtisses du magnifique collégiale de
style renaissance dédiée à saint louis
avec la sainte chapelle funéraire des
bourbeau
[Musique]
les bourbons sont une famille de la très
haute noblesse française descendant de
saint louis par son fils robert de
france
quand louis de montpensier épouser la
fille du seigneur de givry le cardinal
de cette ville bourguignonne donne à la
sainte chapelle de champigny de ces
magnifiques vitraux qu'elle devient l'un
des plus hauts lieux du vitrail de la
renaissance
[Musique]
à chinon
le libre penseur françois rabelais
défend la tolérance et la foi
évangélique original mais il est
aussitôt censuré pour avoir manié trop
crûment la parodie et la satire
rigolarde contre les autorités
ecclésiastiques
c'est l'époque de la remise en question
de l'église de rome
les guerres de religion font rage les
protestants s'empare de tout est détruit
ses oeuvres d'art mais les catholiques
reprennent la ville et égorgent un si
grand nombre de protestants que la loire
se colore de sang enfin par l'horreur du
massacre de protestants à paris le jour
de la saint barthélemy les catholiques
simple
[Musique]
mais quant aux rois catholiques de
france henri iii de valois succède le
prince protestant henri de bourbon
navarre le conflit s'exacerbent les
catholiques de la ligue refuse l'idée
que la couronne de france sacrée par les
papes soit sainte par un protestant
alors henry décide que paris vaut bien
une messe
hab sur le protestantisme et devient
henri iv roi catholique de france mais
son oncle louis premier de bourbon-condé
l'arrogant chef des protestants
huguenots depuis son château de chinon
poursuit la guerre contre les
catholiques
cela n'impressionne pas à marie de
médicis veuve d'henri iv et régnante qui
fait enfermer le prince de condé à la
bastille tandis que le nouveau
secrétaire d'état le cardinal de
richelieu s'attache à rétablir
l'autorité en france
[Musique]
son éminence armand jean du plessis de
richelieu est un décideur n'est devenu
cardinal il fait construire dans le
domaine de ses ancêtres un château et la
villeneuve de richelieu
situé à seulement six kilomètres de
distance le beau château de champigny
sur veude et sa prestigieuse nécropole
des bourbons l'une des sept sainte
chapelle de france portent ombrage au
château et à la ville de richelieu
alors le cardinal convainc gaston
d'orléans frère du roi louis xiii de lui
céder le château de champigny et le
faire raser
[Musique]
puis il menace du même sort le château
de chinon qu'il annexe à son duché par
des intrigues la sainte chapelle n'est
sauvé que par l'intervention du pape
urbain 8 qui avait officié loudun aussi
vit une situation tragique sa forteresse
est démolie par l'armée royale et la
sphère des démons de loudun provoque des
procès en sorcellerie des gens sont
brûlés vifs
[Musique]
quand mazarin succède à richelieu
la fille de gaston d'orléans anne marie
louise conteste le contrat qu'il a pris
de champigny sur veude et on obtient la
restitution petite fille d'henri iv et
cousines du futur roi soleil louis xiv
anne marie louise d'orléans est la
princesse la plus riche et la plus
titrées d'europe par sa mère la duchesse
marie de bourbon montpensier morte en la
mettant au monde
elle devient l'unique héritière de la
richissime famille des bourbons
montpensier son père gaston d'orléans
frère du roi est grand monsieur
s'est mariée contre son gré avec la
duchesse de montpensier pour que sa
fortune reviennent à la famille royale
mais il espérait avoir un fils qui
aurait accédé au trône il eut anne marie
louise une jeune fille ferme et forte
d'esprit est là le titre de grande
mademoiselle du côté de son père
elle attire de nombreux princes qui la
demande en mariage mais elle refuse tout
prétendant doté d'une très haute opinion
de son rang elle ne veut épouser que le
prochain roi son cousin louis xiv mais
louis xiv épouse l'infante d'espagne
alors la grande mademoiselle déplace
c'est attention vers un ennemi du roi
son autre cousin le prince louis ii de
bourbon condé
[Musique]
louis est un rebelle chefs militaires de
la fronde des princes
mais la grande mademoiselle est jeune et
n'a pas peur elle s'associe aux rebelles
et lors d'une bataille
elle fait tirer les canons de la bastide
sur les troupes royales pour protéger
louis de bourbon condé
cet acte vaut l'exil à la grande
mademoiselle exil d'où elle écrit ses
mémoires
confessant un état d'âme sans fausse
pudeur témoignage unique de la vie d'une
femme du xviie siècle
son exil terminer la grande mademoiselle
revient à la cour de louis xiv et tombe
amoureuse d'un cadet de gaz comme de six
ans plus jeune antonin non par deux
comme on compte de lauzun
[Musique]
chéri par les femmes de la cour royale
lauzun est un gentilhomme charmeur et
libre d'esprit il n'est pas riche mais
il est le favori de louis xiv et la
grande mademoiselle qui insiste même
pour l'épousé louis xiv autorise ce
mariage insolite entre une princesse et
un cadet de rang inférieur mais face aux
cris d'indignation de la reine mère
cette union est aussitôt annulée
[Musique]
parce l'époque des merveilles de
versailles de la splendeur de la cour de
france mais le peuple est affamé
le pays est ravagé par l'inflation l'e10
est le brigandage la révolution
française éclate c'est la chasse aux
prêtres et la traque des déserteurs
napoléon bonaparte transforme le royaume
ont république est aboli la noblesse
puis il transforme la république en
empire rétabli la noblesse pour lui et
sa famille et part à la conquête de
l'europe
entre la loire et la vienne rien ne
perturbe la séculaire culture de la
vigne le commerce du vin dont le
transport se fait maintenant par le
chemin de fer référer à la voie fluviale
la guerre contre la prusse et la
première guerre mondiale n'endommage pas
de pot la touraine
mais pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
tours chinon loudun et tant d'autres
villes françaises sont bombardés par la
lute faf est occupée par la paire man et
nazis occupent une moitié de la france
et avance partout c'est le désastre
le pays va devenir allemand
alors à nouveau entre la loire et la
vienne se décident de l'avenir de la
france
le premier ministre du royaume uni
winston churchill rencontre à tour le
général charles de gaulle et le salut en
l'appelant l'homme du destin en effet
sans un lutteur comme le général de
gaulle la france serait aujourd'hui un
land de l'allemagne
[Musique]
sous son commandement la résistance de
la france libre s'organise dans le pays
métropolitain et en outre-mer j'invite
tous les militaires français des armées
de terre de mer et de l'air
ils veulent rester libre dans la forêt
de ces vols et à champigny sur veude des
groupes armés se forment sous le
commandement héroïque de rené mabileau
puis de pierre sécher et de paul
martineau harcelant sans arrêt les
groupes allemands
enfin les alliés débarquent et avec les
français du général de gaulle il libère
paris et les nazis s'enfuit depuis c'est
la paix
l'art et la gloire de nos beaux pays
vallonné entre la loire et la vienne
rayonneront toujours dans nos mémoires
comme les protagonistes à part entière
de l'histoire de france
[Musique]